il est
bonjour à tous on est aujourd'hui chez
cap digital pour parler du futur
capitale organise le festival futur ex
futur en seine et aujourd'hui on parle
de robotique de kobo tic
qu'est ce que la kobo tic qu'est ce que
ça peut nous apporter c'est vraiment un
sujet hyper intéressant et en règle
générale assez méconnu donc on va en
parler aujourd'hui en faire un tour il
ya plein d'exposants ont fait ça
me
[Musique]
m
avec camille qui est l'organisatrice du
festival futur est aujourd'hui sur une
journée qui parle de kobo tic tac aux
gothiques c'est une petite branche de la
robotique qui est en fait un néologisme
une contraction du mot robotique et du
nom collaboratif on parle aussi de
robotique collaborative donc là ça
devient assez transparent je crois qu'on
comprend ce que ça veut dire c'est en
fait des robots ou d'ekobo qui viennent
assister les humains dans des tâches
pénibles et difficiles
s'il ya bien un truc un peu fantasmé
autour de la robotique à usage
professionnel c'est effectivement le
remplacement de l'homme par la machine
et c'est vrai qu'on a vu beaucoup de
gros titres dans les médias qui nous ont
en fait un peu peur qu'il soit et je ne
viens pas vrai les robots vont vous
voyez vos emplois c'est vrai que les
robots vont prendre certains jobs ça
c'est clair mais ce qui est intéressant
dans la critique c'est de voir que nous
il peut y avoir une collaboration entre
entre les humains et les robots et que
les robots vont plutôt venir prendre les
jobs pénible dangereux répétitif et que
les jeunes vont rester sur les tâches à
haute valeur ajoutée sur lesquels ils
peuvent pas être remplacés
et effectivement l'emploi évolué les
métiers et les compétences évolué il ya
déjà des métiers du futur qu'on connaît
pas encore c'est ça qui est intéressant
et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on fait ce
genre d'événement c'est pour comprendre
cette transformation
on est avec olivier olivier est ce que
tu peux nous présenter l'entreprise déjà
ce que vous faites est aperçu on peut
parler de robotique avec plaisir à ma
passion
génial alors cette écoute alors c'était
tel équipement qui fait qu'il ya plus de
40 ans
l'optimisation de mouvements par exemple
le mouvement de l'ascenseur de la tour
eiffel on l'a réglé pour que si on est
quinze d'ascenseur ne sont pas trop bas
sur les faits eux seuls ils soient pas
trop on a fait ce réglages
d'amortisseurs par rapport au poids de
la calle exactement de l'amortisseur
intelligent d'accord ça c'est dans le
public dans l'industriel on a aidé
michelin sur des passes de test à
remplir cinq secondes plus rapidement
ses pneus donc c'est de l'optimisation
du mouvement de la pneumatique
on va également améliorer dans les
usines les plus et les process de
fabrication
la kobo tic ce que tu peux nous
expliquer quel robot collaborative
rambach
j'étais par le définir on commence avec
le robot industriel au basket c'est
vraiment leur dos ils portent une
voiture si tu te mets sur son chemin et
qui sont le nom que du coup ils sont
dans dicale l'avantagent c'est que
laurent industriels qui valait fond la
caisse
il va produire il va tient des cadences
et donc il est rentable mais il n'est
pas flexible donc on va passer sur un
autre robot le co existence
c'est à dire que j'ai un robot
industriel toujours le méchant robot qui
peut couper en deux sauf que celui-là la
place du maître une cage autour fumée un
module ce qui fait que comme chez toyota
par exemple qui est partenaire de kaw si
vous avez des robots industriels sans
cage qui bouge et les opérateurs qui se
balade entre les romans
si je suis à côté le rouet ralenti
si je suis au niveau des trajectoires
alors oui il s'arrête donc là on est sur
quelque chose de flexible mais qui fait
encore un peu peur
ensuite on arrive la robotique
collaborative au sens du terme de la
norme 10 218 1 et 2 la première c'est un
robot qui lui même tout seul sur son
pied comme ça ne peut pas heurter un
humain le robot de m6 collaboratif avec
l'outillage également sur le cas
dureau collaboratif on a une interaction
complète françois la zone et même voir
le l'opération le process de fabrication
c'est à dire qu'on peut même inventé à
monter dans cette idée jamais imaginé
que le robot est un outil dispense de la
colle ou ou un produit et que
l'opérateur viennent en même temps
pierre une opération en même temps que
leur goût ça c'est accepter sur les
robots collaboratif
contrairement à un robot coexistence
parce que il n'a pas d'angle dur c'est
en mousse le robot n'est pas en baisse
mais il ya des protections en mousse et
il a un module de sécurité qui va gérer
tous ses mouvements et qui va l'empêcher
de nous faire mal
pour moi je suis là je suis co fondateur
de leca et chine car on développe ce
petit robot créé de l'ecac au très
mignon était surtout un robot éducatif
d'accord pour les enfants exceptionnels
exceptionnel c'est tous les enfants qui
sont touchés par l'autisme la trisomie
polyhandicap et qui ont besoin de
solutions api novembre pour progresser
et
ok alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec
les cas dans lesquels ils changent de
couleur il roule
il a plein de capteurs pour réagir aux
interactions d'accord puis se connecte à
votre ipad est derrière nous on
développe du contenu éducatif soit sous
la forme d'activités individuel par
exemple qui ont trahi la révélation des
couleurs le tour à tour la motricité
fine sous la forme de contenus plus
pédagogique qu'on appelle des
curriculums sur les ensembles de leçons
avec des objectifs éducatifs un peu plus
précis permettra-il tour à tour avec une
émission on développe tout ça a été des
professionnels des chercheurs on est sûr
que c'est un impact positif faisant on
et robotique dans le sens où on a des
capteurs on va pouvoir agir sur
l'environnement
ok mais on est dans un cadre qui est
extrêmement structurée du fleix contre
avec des enfants en situation de
handicap
le on a des objectifs éducatifs donc on
n'est pas on n'est pas sur un robot qui
a besoin de tout comprendre et
d'analyser l'environnement
nous on va analyser les interactions
plan fort avec le robot mais on sait que
l'interaction est lié au fait qu'on a
demandé à l'enfant de toucher le repos
quand ils élèvent et donc ça nous
simplifie énormément après nos arbres de
décision et
intelligence pour m
ok et donc tout ça est piloté par un
ippon couet au début à la lumière des
gens' dans le robot mais on s'en rend
compte que c'est compliqué d'accord que
les professionnels ou lettres en
contrôler pour être au repos les agents
d'une télécommande mais il fallait les a
très bien et donc pour simplifier le
développement mon ami l'a dit j'en parle
exactement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sylvain est associée d'échappée comment
in time robotique donc vous avez une
espèce de l'écran est placé sur un bras
motorisés savard de l'espèce de réalité
virtuelle
tout ça c'est un casque exactement nous
on est parti du constat que
e
il y avait un vrai développement de là
averts mais qui avait toujours ce
problème de
de l'utilisateur qui est coupé du monde
qui est dans son monde
et du coup qui pose tout un certain
nombre de problèmes notamment sur une
expérience collective sans parler des
expériences de motion sickness de
l'hygiène des casques tout ça et du coup
nous on a proposé en fait on propose une
fenêtre dans un monde à 360° d'accord
l'idée c'est que cette fenêtre pour être
la plus agréable possible qu'elle soit
la plus grande possible
est ce que ça existe déjà avec des
dispositifs
l'iphone qu'on peut manipuler
exactement et du coup pour que cette
fenêtre soit la plus grande possible on
a pris un écran assez grand diddy et
grand écran assez grande île écran qui
pèse son poids et donc pour le manipuler
on a
on utilise en fait un bras robotique qui
permet d'assister en faite le
l'utilisateur dans tous ses mouvements
donc là en temps utile sur la démo on
ces balades autour d'une
exactement qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir
comme com
l'utilité qu'est-ce qu'on peut encore
faire comme application alors il ya
plein d'applications qui sont
imaginables
on reçoit un dispositif qui est assez
proche du dispositif qu'on pourrait
proposer un musée par exemple avec une
oeuvre
modéliser qui est soit en réserve soit
en prêt ça permet de montrer d'une
manière assez ludique
l'écran est tactile donc en plus on peut
on peut imaginer de faire regrouper
toute une série d'informations mais on
peut aussi de déployer dans une boutique
pour présenter des produits
par exemple une paire de chaussures la
regarder ses coutures faire changer de
couleur la paire
ça va être aussi voilà ça peut être
beaucoup d'envié
on peut être aussi envisager des
dispositifs de gaming
voilà par exemple
un jeu avec une voiture ou un vaisseau
spatial et le contrôler directement tour
zac du monde
voilà on y est
on travaille et on aime beaucoup
travailler en fait on
avec le
l'activité
[Musique]
je vous remercie d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo dit man vous ce que vous en pensez
est ce que c'est des sujets qui vous
intéressent
est-ce que la robotique en terme général
quelque chose qui vous passionne on est
vraiment sur une vision du futur
c'est vraiment génial et c'est en ça
effectivement que des festivals comme
futur que des journées comme celles là
sont intéressantes parce qu'elle nous
permette effectivement sentir les
tendances de voir tous ces domaines de
voir les champs d'application et c'est
vraiment passionnant donc vivement vous
ce que vous en pensez en commentaire est
ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
intéressent
oui non quels sont les domaines qui vous
intéresse le plus par rapport à la
robotique en général est-ce qu'on est
plus sûr de leurs robes outils
collaboratifs comme les kobo est ce qu
on est plus sur des assistants
personnels
est ce que vous êtes plus sur
l'intelligence artificielle mark et moi
tout ça on en discute ensemble comme
d'habitude je vous remercie
je vous invite bien évidemment à vous
abonner à rester connectés parce qu'on
va toujours parler plus déjà nos
boutiques de technologies d énormément
de choses qui vont arriver dans les
temps à venir dont je vous invite à
rester connectés à laisser des jeunes
pousses merci beaucoup soyez sages et
puis à très bientôt
ciao